i think we'll have vtol vertical take
off a landing before we have full self
driving
okay veto i love that that sounds like a
pet name
vertical grenade landing those are the
basically like looks like drones or
quadcopters but they actually have
the ones that are kind of tested out a
bit yeah they've been testing them in
china and
they'll be in china and australia and
places like that they're going to work
really well over water
china and then they test them out in
scottsdale arizona usually yeah
no but over water they're great because
you really can't run them over like
brooklyn mm-hmm but you could run them
from
bay ridge at 69th street pier to one of
the heliports on either side of
manhattan from
bay ridge originally that's where i grew
up
arizona right by there they had just
finished it i was born in 1970 they
finished it i think in 60
late 60s underrated bridge beautiful
stunning it was the largest suspension
bridge in the world for a while
it's gorgeous stunning bridge yeah um
but yeah these vetoes that's the thing
that's going to be super exciting
because over water
they can just land and if one of the
rotors goes bad
you have eight rotors 12 rotors on these
things they can actually compensate
you could lose two or three of the
rotors from what i understand from
people who have invested in these
companies
and the other seven will compensate
a bunch yeah well they can just power
this one up more to compensate for the
one that went out
and then it rebalances itself and if you
watch some of these videos online
nick pull up the video of the chinese
company that was going public and that i
had emailed you about
i mean these things are really safe and
they're going to be safer than driving
in cars which is crazy when you think
about it
in the air will be safer than cars
because cars run into each other they
hit things
these things there's nothing to hit you
know you're in the air a chance of
hitting something like
collisions are very rare so this chinese
one uh is from a company called
e hang and their you go to the youtube
channel is just
phenomenal to watch um i think you gotta
go to youtube to watch it it'll be
easier um
but these things uh are going to be the
huge game changer
and they're and they're testing them in
china and you can see multiple videos in
china of ihang
um remotely operated yeah they'll be um
you just go in and the they're remotely
operated so
they can fit i think one human right now
they'll eventually get to four
are we gonna do this before we're doing
delivery be a drone
yeah delivery fight drone is stupid the
thing that's gonna really work is
delivery by
r2d2 or like those little kind of
you know looks like yeah yeah there's
plenty of those going around
yeah they're going to be doing the last
mile stuff it's going to be fantastic if
you have a burrito place in
brooklyn yeah and you're like you throw
five burritos into five compartments
and it's downstairs and they just text
you we're downstairs at your burrito
we'll be here for three minutes come
down now
and then you just go and you type in
your what's that go to drawer number
three go to drawer number three and pull
it out yeah
um and so this this company is called
e-hang and uh they've been
really doing these uh vertical takeoff
landing things and flying them
between self-driving cars this thing
hyperloop
yeah holograms and holograms it's like
zoom that's about like
travel in the future yeah you know
holograms make it so you don't have to
or you have to say or dna but you see
how we're looking at the e-hang right
now you see how many
blades there are and there's two in each
one
so if one gets knocked out the other one
still works and there's one two
three four five six seven eight rotors
there times two sixteen
so it is pretty amazing and larry page i
think invested a hundred million dollars
into each of three of these kitty hawk
being one of them by sebastian thrawn
out here
and so these things are just the game
changer of all game changers
um and over water
if it lands in the water you're gonna
survive
and it's not gonna kill somebody by
landing on somebody's head